uh how are you boys doing good i'm tired
as
all hell because you're in the middle of
moving right now aren't you
by the time this comes out i would have
finished moving yeah but um
yeah like literally tomorrow is the
moving day with me
so i have been just scrambling for the
past week just like clean
i didn't real you don't realize how much
stuff you have in your house
until you start cleaning it's always
like that right because i remember
whenever i would move like you start
packing stuff stuff up and you think to
yourself it's gonna take a day at most
yeah and you pack up like all the main
stuff in like a day you're like oh
i'm 90 of the way packed and then for
some reason all the like the little [ __ ]
that just like gets left over that takes
like two days
let me introduce ourselves because you
own like i feel like 50
of the items you own you never use think
about but you
you think you need them yeah yeah yeah
you also never see them either because
they're like
either put in a closet or like you know
kind of out of sight somewhere right but
like you have like a colander
like you need a colander but like you
don't really think about it until you
you start using it or there you're like
what the [ __ ] do i do
we have like we have this like shaved
ice machine
that uh i think i think maylene got it
for us but uh we we had it for like the
last summer because melia was like oh i
want to like come to your guys's place
and like
the girls can have like a kind of girls
like day and we can just make shaved ice
or whatever
never used it yeah let's oh we do okay
we used to once
we used the ones and it's just this huge
brick of a thing that's just like
sitting in the kitchen i'm like why is
this here
there's always that one draw in every
kitchen right that is just
the unused appliance drawer right where
it's just these appliances that people
give you as gifts
or that you think is going to be cool
when you host like that dinner party
that never happens
and then there's just these like random
appliances that just get put into this
drawer
and you forget you even have exactly
exactly we have like
forks use my hands
yeah well i i uh i got um this kind of
cleaning service thing because okay
one thing okay we're immediately going
to go on to this is one thing i hate
about japan throwing away trash
right okay and especially the big trash
yeah right because like in australia
yeah yeah just pick myself
but um because like i don't know about
in the uk but in australia we have like
this thing i think it happens once every
two or three months
uh it's called like council cleanup day
so basically what we do is we take
huge appliances like couches beds you
know
drawers all that kind of stuff yeah and
we literally just throw it out
in front of the street like just onto
the street and
basically it's you know you throw it out
um people can kind of walk around and
just
you know grab stuff if they want like if
they think oh you know i can i think
two to three months it's like every two
to three months or something have i
never seen
it really in australia yeah it happens i
i don't know if maybe that's just like
the area yeah
in the uk in the uk i don't think
there's enough space to just throw oh i
thought in japan for a second
we just throw stuff out and then big
garbage truck basically comes and
collects all the stuff that doesn't get
picked up after like a week
i think right um japan doesn't work like
that so like we had to throw away
our bed which is like a queen size bed
yeah a couch
and like couple of tables and like a
sofa and stuff like that
a lot of big stuff but like you can't
just throw it out with the rest of the
trash
you have to either you have to go to
your like local
council and be like i want to throw this
stuff away and they give you these like
tickets that you have to pay for
yeah to basically be like all right i'm
throwing this out on this day and then
you throw it out onto this you have to
book it and tell them you have to book
it i need to tell them the exact
measurements of the thing so yeah
or what i found out is you can just
there's just services out there that you
can just call up and be like
i want to throw all this crap away how
much is it to get rid of yeah yeah a
little more expensive than like the
whole council thing but
so much easier i mean it's it's not a
price for me it's like
like we talked about last week it's just
getting the paperwork done yeah that
like
[ __ ] i'm scared of yeah exactly and
like i'm not even finished with the
[ __ ] paperwork too because i have to
do more after we move
yeah yeah yeah cause japan is just like
a never-ending sea of paperwork
but like i was like okay i'm getting rid
of this giant bed i'm getting rid of
this couch this table all these like big
appliances
yeah and i'm like okay well these are
the big things gone so
you know maybe like 30 of my belongings
probably gone it's more like three
percent
i feel like in like your bedroom or
office there's so many little things
you should never think about especially
my office yeah and my office is so many
little things i'm just like i'm
i'm well first of all i'm looking
forward to like the moving company
coming in
and seeing like all of like my [ __ ]
skateboards and [ __ ] like that just
being like whoa
they'll be like yo is that is that a rem
eight one eighth scale
giving them a tour of your house you're
like yeah so this is this is the jojo
store actually to be fair that when the
moving guy first came in to like check
to see what we had
he walked into my office and he was like
whoa
otaku's dream he's like wow jesus this
guy's gonna [ __ ] collect
like the opposite happen where like i i
i only
use my tatami room to film in and i only
use it so i have a big tatami room that
i normally do the cosplay videos in
yeah you have really bad sorry i never
clean them up after i just leave the
cosplays there until i do the next video
and then i clean it up
and then one time they didn't tell me
they were doing this but there was like
uh they were checking like the fire
alarms
in the building right and i was like
yeah sure come in come in
and he's going around my house he goes
into my office you know he looks
he's like oh i'm like yeah i like jojo
looked at me like i was [ __ ] weird
and i was like all right thanks buddy
and then and then as he went to like my
tatami room i was like oh [ __ ] i just
remembered that all my [ __ ] was in there
and so like i i go in to check that he's
there and this man is just standing in
the middle of like my cosplay everywhere
it's this stuff reached holding up
something to the fire alarm just looking
like look down don't look
don't look at anything and then after
this guy left really awkwardly an hour
later someone else came along
from the same company in the building
and did the exact same thing
yeah and i was like wait why am i being
checked twice oh he's like a spot man
i don't know like i was really just
gonna make sure my friend got it right
you know you say yo i heard this free
cosplay wasn't that
okay and then i had the exact same
interaction again where i was like oh
yeah
sorry about the mess in this room by the
way i like jojo by the way i also like
jojo
oh really [ __ ] weirdo
but luckily like we yeah like as i said
i'm pretty sure i mentioned in the
previous podcast episode
we got to service that where they just
do all the packing for us yeah my god i
cannot imagine
if i had to do that all myself god i
just kind of realized what
i'm gonna have to go through when we
move um because
my room's gonna be fine um but then i
got sydney's room yeah
which the amount of [ __ ] [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and sit there
so well be careful that's the [ __ ] of
the round that looks expensive
so i remember i remember this one time
we we had to get like our doorbell fixed
right
so we we thought we thought our house
was pretty clean basically whenever
someone needs to come in to check
our house at all we just make sure like
sydney's room is just [ __ ] locked off
it's it's it's like a quarantine section
you know
you gotta put up like a
you put the [ __ ] biohazard sign on
the door just to make sure no one gets
in right but radioactive right yeah yeah
so so how we learned our lesson was we
had our door
we had a doorbell fix and of course
sydney's room was like cordoned off
but we forget that sometimes sydney just
has
[ __ ] lying about the house right and i
guess we've just become so desensitized
to some of the stuff she reviews my my
fiance reviews a lot of lewd stuff
that's that's
that's her channel so we just had like a
bunch of figures
that were just left in the living room
with just like their tits out right
so so this guy this guy just comes in
right and
um the the doorbell's like right next to
the kitchen
and also we have a shelf right next to
the kitchen which just has
two lewd completely naked figures just
right next to where the doorbell is
he takes a look at looks at the figures
looks at sydney
and just doesn't make eye contact with
sydney ever again he's got like hentai
here
just sweating yeah that was probably the
longest [ __ ] hour he had to like
enjoy his life when he was just fake i
love how he immediately looked at sydney
like
you wouldn't think that like you're
looking like gone right being like this
[ __ ] right
he's like leaving his little [ __ ] out no
immediately went to see me he's like god
i wish that was me
i wish my wife would let me put my my
dirty fingers in god
yeah it's the one time whenever someone
comes around and i'm just like yo this
these loose stuff that's that's not me
guys guys that's not me it's it's my
partner you're just like silently yeah
yeah
no no seriously seriously it's my
partner this time
yeah i i mean i had to like because i
have like quite a few like dojins and
stuff like that in my bookshelf as well
so i was like i'll pack these away
before i
uh because like i'm with these guys for
like a couple of days
yeah like i don't want like an awkward
experience for a couple of days as they
like sift through my dozens being like
so what's the fragile stuff and what's
not the fragile stuff